[Music]  it's a world of opportunity  and i was meant for more in this life  [Music]  whether you have the killer instinct is  a big question  i hope i don't know  [Music]  i am a woman hear me raw  all right we should put on some music or  something lighten the mood  from the very beginning i realized i saw  the world differently than everyone else  [Music]  that didn't sit well with some people  but i wasn't for everyone  [Music]  i guess they were always scared that i'd  be  a psycho  but a new day brings new opportunities  and i was ready to make a statement  how does the same girl  i am woman hear me raw  i'm just getting started darling  the thing is i was born  a little bit mad  [Music]  bye